هذه اجزاء من منطقه الشاطئ الشمالي البيوت
المتلاصقه كلها مدمر قوات الاحتلال دمرت
كل هذه المنطقه بشكل فعلي لا يمكن معرفه
ملامح هذه المنطقه عدد البنايات كبير جدا
عشرات البنايات المدمره حتى عدد الطوابق
السكنيه لا يمكن معرفته بسبب الدمار
الكبير في كافه البنايات داخل هذا المكان
لا يمكن تمييز ال البيوت عن بعضها البعض
دمار هائل جدا ولا يمكن استيعاب حجم هذا
الدمار بعد ان كانت هذه المنطقه ممتلئه
بالبنايات السكنيه الان مئات العائلات بلا
ماوى بلا مكان الكل يعلم ايضا قدوم الان
فصل الشتاء مئات العائلات التي تسكن داخل
هذه
البنايات الان هي بلا
ماوى كلما تقدمنا كلما تكشف حجم الدمار
اكثر كل البنايات الموجوده في هذا المكان
هي اصلا مدمره وكشف الدمار مع كل
خطوه نتقدم بها الى
الامام ايضا في هذا المكان سيارات
محترقه يحاول الكثير من النازحين العوده
الى هذه الاماكن واخراج ما تبقى من اثار
هذا
الدمار نحن الان في منطقه اخر الشمالي وهي
النقطه الاخيره في منطقه مخيم الشاطئ او
منطقه الشاطئ الشمالي على هذه الناحيه
الدمار الكبير في منطقه الشاطئ الشمالي
وعلى الناحيه الاخرى تتواجد قوات الاحتلال
وتمنع اي مواطن الوصول الى هذا المكان
باطلاق الرصاص الكثيف عليه ما بين فينه
واخرى اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه
غزه